hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
no it isn't sorry it's time for the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcasted
ah i'm just checking in on you
seeing how you doing how's your work
week going huh you hanging in there you
staying positive
i'm staying positive i'm not letting the
world get me down
you know i i put a smile on my face
before i walk out the door
morning neighbor
um sky rocket in flight
la's still on fire it's just on fire man
there's just smoke
you know just [ __ ] you know and
people are leaving
and they're they're they're talking of
there's so many [ __ ] people leaving
weak huh
couple of forests catch
i'm staying man i'm gonna be the last
[ __ ] guy out here
like some [ __ ] sci-fi movie you know
i'll move into whatever uh hollywood
hills mansions haven't burned out
but you're all by myself just shouting
out into the [ __ ]
smoke-filled night i win i beat you
all you couldn't take it man
that's what it is
going gets tough
the tough get going um
no i totally understand people leaving
and there's so many [ __ ] people
leaving and this state is so mismanaged
and uh oh [ __ ] orange had [ __ ]
destroyed this state in taxes on not not
saying that he [ __ ] it up 100
but he he kind of gave it the final
overhand right
you know and um you know he
trump knocked the mouthpiece we were
already going down and then it was the
overhand right it was [ __ ] over
because
you know these [ __ ] liberals
[ __ ] out here can't keep their
goddamn mouth shut
you know i swear to god they would just
that's why don't believe these stupid
presidential polls either
this is the thing conservatives they're
conservative people they're not telling
you who they're voting for
liberals lit flapping their [ __ ]
can't shut the [ __ ] up about what
they're doing and what other people
should be doing
all right those polls are [ __ ]
it's any man's game any old [ __ ]
wrinkled white man's game i cannot
believe
these two crypt keepers these these are
the two [ __ ] people
you know unfucking believable
it's been a while since there's been a
couple of good i'm trying to think the
last time there was
two quality [ __ ] people
running maybe mccain and obama
sort of but even them they get eaten up
by the [ __ ] machine you still do
whatever though did i just say the
machine oh man
you you talking about corporations bill
um sorry um yeah these uh
these fires and the santa ana winds are
coming which is gonna [ __ ] whip [ __ ]
around it's just gonna be
uh i don't know what but um we're gonna
figure this stuff out i really believe
that we are
and uh i i heard that they're coming up
with a if you leave the state they're
talking about coming up with
a capital gains tax if you leave the
state literally i live in a state
that is trying to hold its people
hostage
[Laughter]
there's no business like show business
like no business i know
everybody that i know is leaving um
whatever still a great place when it's
not on fire man i gotta tell you
something this place is [ __ ] um
like a lot of things if it isn't on fire
it's amazing the only thing that's
that's better when it's on fire is like
a fire pit
right or a grill everything else if it's
on fire
it's it's just not it's not a good deal
oh really bill we didn't realize that
we didn't realize that look at these
people just chowing down i got the uh
the world serious on here there's
another hit over the head
[ __ ] tampa bay hanging in there
had a five to nothing lead then the
dodgers
oh and i was loving the guy pitching for
the dodgers too this giant [ __ ]
redhead he was like the paul bunyan or
redheads
he had a [ __ ] insane mullet going
right sort of a puerto rican style beard
you know the skinny or the latinos
sort of shave on it you know um
and then uh they were down five nothing
he gave up he gave up like a two run
[ __ ] shot to make it five nothing i
don't know who started the game
but uh i don't know who won game one i
was assuming the dodgers did
i like watching the world series i like
october baseball i like joe buck i like
this whole [ __ ] thing
um and it's not even weird anymore
without a crowd so it is six to three
the top of the seventh tampa bay's got
one on and what's great about this
is either los angeles or tampa bay is
going to win two titles
in uh like two months
basically right let's see uh tampa bay
won the stanley cup when did they win it
uh
mid-september right and lakers just won
the nba title so somebody's gonna get a
world series and a stanley cup or a
world series
and a nba title which i think is pretty
cool
i like that i root for [ __ ] people
i've let go of all of my [ __ ]
i root for every [ __ ] root for
whatever i'm going pau i'm going
positive all right
when you live in a world where people
are saying let's drop a nuclear bomb
into the hurricane maybe that will help
it out
it's time you took you just got to root
for [ __ ] good [ __ ] to happen for
people i i i
really believe that speaking which i got
caught up here now that i'm back
uh out here in la um
i got caught up on all the moto gp races
i am 100
caught up and once again addicted to the
sport i just got so [ __ ] busy
with all of this stuff dad stuff travel
stuff
uh gigs and [ __ ] um
i gotta tell you this is what if you're
not into this sport yet i have to tell
you
what the [ __ ] is basically
um brewing
okay so you got mark marquez he's
basically
the lebron of the sport like the top guy
right now right
and on first or second race of the year
he had a high side
and he broke his humorous he tried to
come back the next race he just couldn't
do it and they just shut it down so he's
out for the year
and evidently i didn't i wasn't aware of
this he has a brother
i believe alex marquez right
so he uh he was the moto 2
champion so that's the level right below
it's like
you know aaa before you get called up to
the mages right
and he was the champion of that and i
guess when he got
uh when he got on a team he got a ride
at the upper level that his brother
mark marquez was at there was some
people grumbling being like
the only reason why i go to [ __ ] rug
is because she's mark's brother
blake if lebron james brother got
drafted in the nba
and people were [ __ ] grumbling about
that well guess guess what
this kid over the last two races just
showed that he's for [ __ ] real
um both races he was like 11th or 12th
uh the previous race the one in
france in lamar he went from like 11th
up to like fourth or something and then
this pass race he was like in 10th or
11th and went all the way up to second
place
and um was riding like his brother
which is setting up next year
when his brother mark marquez comes back
you're gonna have mar two brothers both
riding hondas
riding against each other that's gonna
be amazing and then wherever uh
andre davizioso ends up who he's kind of
had an interesting strategy where i feel
like uh i don't know what goes on with
those ducatis
i was talking to alonzo bowden who's a
big race fan too he's trying to claim
that the uh
maybe i don't i don't want to misquote
him but i think he was saying that those
ducatis are so
they got so much power or whatever that
they chew up the tires you really got to
be careful
regardless of what what you know soft
medium or hard they put on there
and i've noticed davizioso seems to be
content with being about an
eighth or ninth for the first half of
the race and then he really starts
to roll on the throttle and try to work
his way up
um i don't know but um so
was it it's johan mir he's in first
place with points fabio cuatro
who had a brutal race um i know he had
two i think he had two high sides uh
qualifying [ __ ] up his hips or
something
alluding to that and i never watch
qualifying i don't know if that's true
maverick vignellis
so it's 121 points 115 109. andre
davizioso's got 106.
and then uh i hope we say his name
takaki
nagagami who i love the way he rides
rides to honda japanese rider he's uh
in fifth place with 92 points so it's
gonna be amazing there's like four or
five races left
there seems to be a different winner
every single race
and now all of a sudden um
alex marquez is riding like a like his
brother
so he's kind of like messing things up
for people
while also making a name it's just gonna
be an incredible season so i'm really
excited about that
and also i watched a bunch of football i
got caught up on that
and i really got into what's a fun team
to watch is the uh
arizona cardinals that
kyla murray jesus that is the fastest
[ __ ] quarterback i've seen since mike
vick when he played in atlanta
now he's like a goddamn water bug out
there
so [ __ ] fast um
and through a number of deep balls this
guy number 13 i don't know all the names
made an incredible fingertip catch they
kicked the [ __ ] out of the dallas
cowboys
i mean that [ __ ] nfc east my god
it's i don't know it's just a weird time
they got a bunch of new head coaches and
they got a bunch of
rookie quarterbacks also doesn't help
the cowboys that
prescott was out uh but they had andy
dalton it's like they had some bum under
center
former starting quarterback right don't
think that that's that bad
so anyways my new england patriots the
covid pats we got uh
the san francisco 49ers who do not have
a former
patriot jimmy garoppolo under center i
know he's hurt also unless he's coming
back i have no idea
um we shall see we shall see what
happens
with all of that type of stuff um
i'm getting excited though i'm i'm
getting back i'm flying uh
you know provided the smoke is low
enough i'm gonna fly
tomorrow i don't know we'll see flying
with an instructor gonna
get back into it i haven't flown in like
a month so i'm always super careful but
i'm also excited because uh
the place where i rent from is getting a
new helicopter
and uh it's a much safer one than the
one that i fly so i'm kind of
really excited about that of course i'll
have to get some hours on it
um but uh
i'm very excited because the one that i
fly
i mean you know it's you if you know
what areas to stay away from it's still
super safe but this thing is just it's
just nice
to have a little more inertia in the uh
main road of blade is a shady
um so anyway i'm watching this [ __ ]
what is it the uh dodgers in tampa bay i
should probably look it up to see what
the deal is with that
um anyway my kids are [ __ ] so goddamn
funny man
both of them my son in the last
um like week and a half
all of a sudden just like he totally
gets
how to just reach up and grab stuff he
put it together
so fast and uh one of the doctors was
saying that he really has
really good hand-eye coordination so of
course me as a dad i'm like oh my god
you know he's going to be in the nfl you
know whatever
he's going to be a pro baseball player
um
but he's put that together and uh
he now he knows how to kind of push
himself backwards he kind of figured
that out today where he planted his
little
baby meaty forearms you know kind of
pushed himself backwards and it's funny
because he wants to go
forward so he's excited that he's moving
but he's frustrated that he's not going
in the uh
the right direction but this kid i'm
telling you man
the smiles this kid gives you it's his
whole
face he does that thing you know that
600-yard stairs babies have when you
walk into the room
like who the hell's that guy then they
figure it out and they break into this
giant smile
it's just the greatest thing ever and
then my daughter is like
i don't know she's like she loves
to roughhouse so i have to understand
that after she gets up from her nap
that and then she has dinner or whatever
you know a little bit later on
um i try to wear her out playing t-ball
and stuff but they just
you know they're brand new they can just
go forever so i usually start conking
out like around
seven and then that's when she wants to
like jump on my back
or have me chase her around the kitchen
and stuff so of course i do it
because i'm a [ __ ] lunatic right i
like doing that stuff
um but she
jumped off the uh she has this thing if
i'm laying
on the ground she thinks this is
hilarious if i'm laying on my back
watching tv you know feet on the floor
knees up right
and i'm just on the ground she comes
walking in walks right up to me
turns around leaps up into the air and
then
butt first lands on my stomach and i
just go
oh and she just thinks it is the
funniest i've learned to anticipate it
and the only thing i can do is i just
i just sort of do a bridge as i lift my
stomach up so it's
closer to when her body weight is coming
down so it doesn't hurt as much
so she does that and the more she hurts
me the funnier
i mean the funnier she thinks it is so
tonight we were playing and uh
you know it bugs my wife because we do
play a little bit rough and occasionally
she bumps her head or something and
cries and then it becomes like you know
she gets mad which she should so today
i was with my son and he was on his back
playing with like the mobile
things or whatever and she kept
jumping on my back off of the couch
and when she'd jump on my back like i
was a horse i would then just stand up
and then like flip her off and she'd
land on the couch
every dad out there right now knows
where this is going
my wife's sitting there on the couch so
she did something where rather than she
was sort of jumping
half jumping on because as i was really
close i was a little far
further away from the couch and she did
like a superfly snooker
for wrestling fans out there jumped off
the top rope essentially
and overshot my back landed on my left
shoulder
and sta almost started to go head first
to the ground but you know i i
did the dad save where i i just reached
up and i was able to grab her before
and then she was sort of upside down her
back on my forearm and then her feet hit
the ground
and oh my god my wife was so [ __ ] mad
and it was the weirdest thing she was
mad and i just was bursting out laughing
and she was going it's not funny and i
go no no this is
this is how i've always reacted to
getting into trouble
it's like a nervous reaction when i know
i'm wrong and i get caught i would
always
die laughing which [ __ ] destroyed me
in school because the teachers would
think that i was laughing at him
and i wanted to be like no i'm laughing
because it's an anxiety that i'm in
trouble and i know i'm wrong
so i started laughing and she got so
[ __ ] mad at me but i was able to
explain it to her
you see that you go to therapy you learn
how to [ __ ] express yourself you know
and then hopefully
you know the goddamn broads there will
leave you
at least understand you a little more
right i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about
um so anyway i gotta read some
advertising here at some point
uh let's do some nfl predictions here as
i'm getting [ __ ] smoked on my bookie
um all right nfl.com all right
who do we got coming up here i'm going
to give you how many of you
oh billy red faces pics of the week
billy redface pick of the week oh for
god's sakes who has the slowest internet
in the world
i do i do maybe i'll do it after the
[ __ ] reads but you'll have to get up
on my phone for some reason
it's not really the internet at this
point i i really think that it's um
i think it really has to do with the the
smoke
it's in the air i mean i think it's just
blocking the satellite signal i mean at
some point
that has to come into play no
correct oh [ __ ] me so now this thing
isn't gonna load come on come on
oh the wheel's spinning the wheel's
spinning oh and it tells me to go [ __ ]
myself
come on can i just [ __ ] knock out a
[ __ ] podcast
so i can have a morning to myself
[ __ ] hell every [ __ ] i swear to
god man
any [ __ ] time you try to get a
[ __ ] head it's like the universe
knows
it's a [ __ ] nose jesus
[ __ ] christ
come on you [ __ ] [ __ ] i knew it i
[ __ ] why do i
why do i care why do i care
why do i try
you gotta be my phone won't the [ __ ]
goddamn
[ __ ] laptop won't either
but no i'm gonna stay positive i'm gonna
stay positive let's see with texting
works
let me let me see andrew here can
you text
ads to me
[ __ ] internet
there we go that should be enough right
i think everybody can relate to that
type of situation you know are you joe
six-pack do you put your [ __ ] pants
on one goddamn thing at a time
all right i believe it's still six to
three what am i gonna do play-by-play
here while i wait for these things to
come in
oh [ __ ] he's got a signal
ladies and gentlemen he's got a signal
maybe if you learn to be patient maybe
if you learn to go [ __ ] yourself
all right now we're now we're trying to
load the next page
all right what ending is it it is the
top of the eighth it is six
to three six to three
is there a name for the beard without
the mustache
i'm not talking like a neck beard like
you have a full
[ __ ] like 1800s president
beard and then for whatever reason like
your mustache
is either drawn in or it just won't grow
in
i don't know now for god's sakes can you
just how about these [ __ ] people that
go to the goddamn games
i mean how big a baseball fan are you
that you're willing to risk killing your
grandparents
there's nothing to worry about we have
the best hospitals
if you get coveted a helicopter will
show up to the house you don't pay for
where you would then be whisked off and
have the top doctors in the [ __ ]
world
with experimental medicine
yeah or you go to a [ __ ] overcrowded
hospital if you're a regular person and
sit in the [ __ ] hallway in a
ventilator
you know tomato tomato
when and oh i got them here they've been
texted to me they've been texted to me
all right here we go ladies and
gentlemen
miracles never cease to happen
and of course the part of the [ __ ]
password doesn't work all right here we
go all right all right all right
oh look who it is everybody who is it
jesus [ __ ] christ is a lot of [ __ ]
here
all right oh frame bridge everybody do
you like taking pictures
do you frame bridge frames frame bridge
makes it
easy easier and more affordable than
ever to frame your favorite things
without ever leaving the house add a
gallery wall to your home office
or send the perfect gift from at prints
and diplomas to the photos sitting on
your phone you can
frame bridge you can frame bridge just
about anything there's no [ __ ] way
how long it took me to get through
college that i'm sending my [ __ ]
diploma anywhere
uh here's a reminder of how it works
just go to framebridge.com
uh and upload your photo or they'll send
you packaging
to safely mail in your physical pieces
uh preview your item online in dozens of
frame styles and gallery wall layouts
choose your favorite i just pictured
people at freybridge looking at some of
these pictures going
who the [ __ ] would want to frame this uh
choose your favorite
or get free free recommendations free
recommendations
from their talented designers the
experts at framebridge will custom frame
your item and deliver your finished
piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you pay at a framing store their prices
start at 39
and all shipping is free plus my
listeners
uh will get 15 off their first order at
framebridge.com
when they use my code burr b-u-r-r get
started today give your personal
experience using framebridge
um oh i'll give my personal experience i
told my wife to use it and they
they sent out frame photos of my dog
cleo and i
still have them to this day and they did
a great job then i'm sure you guys can
figure out how to use it because you're
smart
uh get started today frame your photos
send someone the perfect gift go to
framebridge.com and use the promo code
burb b-u-r-r
to save an additional 15 off your first
order just go to framebridge.com promo
code bur
framebridge.com promo code burr oh look
who's bat
back movement watches mvmt
mike victor mike tango has watches
sunglasses or other accessories
uh have been the perf what mbt mvp
mvmt sorry has watches sunglasses or
other accessories
have been the perfect gifts for family
friends significant others etc
what kind of a sentence is that movement
has watches sunglasses or other
accessories
have been should be that have been the
perfect gifts for family friends
significant others etc
movement watchers are all about looking
good while keeping it simple
they don't tell you how to many steps
you've taken or blow your wrist up with
text messages
um they're not overly intrusive on life
with notifications text messages emails
etc
they tell they tell time like true
classic timepieces should and look good
doing
it they have rugged watches for when
you're active and more formal watches
for you
if you're going to be the dapper dan at
the [ __ ] party there
uh they have lots of sharp looking
sunglasses for men and women
there's their story a crowd-funded
startup by two guys who understood what
it was like living under a tight budget
because they lived it too
movement watchers started at just 95
uh you're looking at 400 for the same
quality from a traditional band
movement has sold almost two million
watches in over 160 countries gets 15
off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to
slash burr mvmt.com movements launching
new styles
on their site all the time check out
their latest at movement.com
mvmt.com go to mvmt.com
join the movement now what else do we
got here who the hell are these guys
some new
thera gun there gun
uh
[Music]
there again the stress of daily life
weighs is this a gun
you can have my theory gun when you prac
for my cold dead fingers
or if you ask me nicely i think you're
good [ __ ] all right
theragan the stress of daily life weighs
on all of us whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person
trying to get through the day muscle
pain and muscle tension is a real thing
next please mention all the talking
points below
that's why there is theragun the
handheld percussive therapy device that
releases your deepest muscle tension
using a scientifically calibrated
combination
of depth speed and power and now and now
as quiet as an electric toothbrush
that's because the all-new gen 4
theragun has a property
proprietary brushless motor that's so
quiet
you will wonder if it's on while you
soothe your aching muscles
with theragan's signature power
amplitude and effectiveness
try theragun for 30 days there is no
substitute for a theragun
gen 4 with an oled
screen uh personalized tarragon
app and the quiet and power you need
starting at 199
i have one of these things these things
are incredible if you got old legs like
me they are
friggin amazing uh go to theragun.com
right now and get your gen 4 theragun
today that's
theragun.com t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n-dot-com
slash bur theragun.com slash burr
it's a thera gun let's see the liberals
take that away
um you can have my self-massaging
theragun
when you pry it from my assistant's
dead fingers i don't know what i'm
saying here um
anyway plowing ahead here i thought
tampa was going to add an insurance run
there evidently they did
not evidently
they did not hey you know i've been i
started following on
instagram who seems to have a really
good podcast the clips he's putting up
is
that uh the rapper fat joe i just saw a
clip on instagram
he had um uh what the [ __ ] his name
god damn it i am the i
what is i can't remember anything i
literally owned cassette tapes and cds
buster rhymes
he had buster rhymes on he told this
amazing story
about uh tupac and q-tip
and the argument that they had i believe
in the hip-hop world it's called
beef um
check that guy he said so really he's
also the reason why
i downloaded this album because i
started following i forget how i started
you know somebody post something you
find interesting it's like oh i'll
follow this guy see what's going on with
this guy
so i he's the reason why i now listen to
oh [ __ ] where the hell is it i got to
make sure i get his [ __ ] name right
god damn it bill
he's the reason why i listen to
uh hector lavaux he said
he's the greatest salsa singer of all
time i was like i don't know [ __ ] about
salsa
so i downloaded his greatest hits and i
can't get enough of it it's [ __ ]
amazing
i believe j.lo and that dude
who looks like anthony kumia that she
married
at one point um
made a movie about the guy oh
[ __ ] what the hell's the guys isn't the
guy's name mark
well i can just look her up with my
internet but if i wasn't under like
[ __ ]
9 000 feet of smoke uh
all right guys i want you guys to uh
send me the top four places where you
think i should move if i have to if this
whole place really catches if all these
people
leaving are right and i have to leave
here
i don't think i'm gonna because i just
feel like
if enough people leave
then in la becomes the population it
should be
just being able to get on the highway
and cruise around all the time would be
great like like
there's covet all the time except it's
not covered
holy [ __ ] he took a deep whoa
not like i'm rooting for the dog i'm
kind of rooting for the dodgers man
they've been that knocking on the door
for so long
i gotta find out if uh but tampa bay's
never won a world series have they
i always get them confused with the
lightning the lightning won it in 2004
and they won it this year
they got two stanley cups they have one
super bowl
and they've never won a world series no
they have not
they haven't all right i just confirmed
that in my head
and what the hell was i looking up oh
world series world
series 2020 come on kershaw come on come
on they never give him any [ __ ] run
support and then everybody [ __ ]
blames him it's so stupid
um all right whatever you guys already
know the [ __ ] answer to it i'll look
it up at some point
i was surprised that redheaded dude on
the dodgers where it's number 10. wasn't
that ron says number i was surprised
they uh the penguin there they didn't
the dodgers never retired that one i
find franchises either retire
every [ __ ] number or they're just
like [ __ ] this
you know i don't give a [ __ ] we don't
retire numbers
and i think as a player you have to feel
good about going to a franchise
that will oh my god what the [ __ ] are
they doing
holy [ __ ]
my god that [ __ ] guy there the
redheaded dude just hit a [ __ ]
blooper
the goddamn guys in the outfield
what are they doing i'll tell you right
now there's a lot of women getting
beaten on houseboats in tampa right now
sorry um it's a rough state okay people
i i don't create the rules
um they haven't lost it yet there's a
lot of nervous
what did they used to call that if you
lived with a woman long enough
uh there's a lot of nervous common-law
women
on houseboats in tampa right now
six to four the tying run has come to
the plate
the dodgers they've been there knocking
on the door so many times
they knocked on a door they should have
knocked on a trash can
sorry um yeah i think i might have to
i don't know i really like obviously
like l.a i live out here
but i also you know come on how how how
many times
have have the the tampa bay devil raised
don't say devil it makes me nervous how
many
how many times have the rays
um developed a player only to have the
player
leave and go to a bigger market so i
think i might have to root for them but
i also want to root for
i i'll be happy either way i think i
kind of got to go dodgers just because
kershaw has taken so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know somehow he
loses it
himself every goddamn
october i i don't buy it so um i think
i'm gonna root for them
but i'll obviously be happy if tampa
wins all right that's it that's the
podcast everybody
um please enjoy the music and then
there's gonna be a
greatest hits thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
coming
after the uh the music picked out by the
wonderful
and very talented andrew themless have a
great weekend you can't hey what's going
on it's bill burr
and it's the monday morning podcast for
monday october 22nd
2012 and i know what you're thinking
bill why does it sound like you're
inside of a [ __ ] tin can well i'll
tell you why
i'm in [ __ ] australia i just plugged
my goddamn mixer into the [ __ ]
adapter and it just shorted it out
all right it's my fault what was i
thinking
running such a gigantic podcast such as
the monday morning podcast with a 99
mixer and i did say gigantic podcast
this is a big podcast it's [ __ ] big
to me
every week on itunes we're number 37.
you like that i'm the only podcaster who
doesn't lie
all these [ __ ] out there every [ __ ]
one of them dude i got like a million
downloads i'm number one i'll go [ __ ]
yourself yeah when you get number one in
your ass
um
i'm here to tell you that i am number 18
and i'm proud of it
so anyways i don't have any headphones i
don't need a microphone i'm recording
this thing through garageband and this
is how it's going to sound
all right and if you don't want to
listen to it just hit stop because it's
not going to get any [ __ ] better than
this
all right you like how i'm kind of
yelling at you because
my mix because i bought a 99 mixer
to run the 47th top 47th podcast on the
[ __ ] itunes
um all right let's get right down to it
lance armstrong officially [ __ ]
stripped of all of his goddamn
titles and nike has the [ __ ]
balls the [ __ ] balls to walk away
from lance
you didn't walk away from tiger woods
you know
after all the [ __ ] he was doing
so i guess if lynch just [ __ ] around
on his wife
you know you still would have had a
swish above his [ __ ] left hit you
wouldn't have a problem with it
hey nike where the [ __ ] do you get off
having any sort of
moral stance about cheating or not
cheating
you know if you're taking a look at your
company lately
you think lance doesn't have the right
to [ __ ] go around handing out those
live
strong bracelets because you think he
cheated well what about
you guys what about you nike
just do it what does that mean is that
what you say to the children who sew
your sneakers together in el salvador
um yeah where the [ __ ] does nike get i
mean
you know what it is i love that that's
when nike drops them and it gets to look
like they don't tolerate
cheating it's all about money with those
[ __ ] they don't give a flying [ __ ]
whether he cheated whether he didn't
cheat all right when it looked
emphatically like this guy had been
busted they walk away
like well that's not what we're about if
anybody out there can explain to me
what [ __ ] nike is about other than
money
and standing on the heads of
eight-year-olds
um you know if you can come up with
something else send me an email
i cuz i for one would love to hear it
all right i hope this isn't really uh i
hope this recording isn't as bad
as it looks looks like i'm [ __ ]
blowing out your eardrums i'm trying
here people
a little handicapped here i'm down under
having a nice time down and
um oh jesus christ
i [ __ ] made it over here everybody
14-hour flight
you know and with no drugs
i was thinking of you know watching a
couple of movies and then taking some
drugs and i actually i worked it out
i got on the plane i immediately fell
asleep
and i slept for maybe i don't know about
six
hours and then i just watched movies
well what'd you watch bill while i
watched caddyshack
then i watched on the waterfront then i
watched
national lampoon's vacation
chevy's chase still [ __ ] hilarious
and then i watched uh
a beegee's documentary which got
really [ __ ] boring really quickly
and uh then all of a sudden we landed
and that was it so there you go i know i
watched something else in there there
was something else random that i started
to watch
i started watching a couple of
documentaries and i know what you think
about
what who the [ __ ] would ever watch a
goddamn documentary on the bee gees
well you know i had 14 hours to kill all
right you judgmental
[ __ ] and not to mention the bgs are from
australia i figured maybe i'd see
something in there that i could bring to
my live
shows um
or whatever so we land we land here at
like 6 30 in the [ __ ] morning
we basically we left at 10 o'clock at
night monday night
flew for 14 hours and by the time we got
here
it was 6 30 wednesday morning
you lose a day you know there's an
18-hour [ __ ] difference between
l.a and here i don't know if this is
interesting i don't know if you can hear
me
you know i don't [ __ ] know
um but uh yeah so then it was weird
because then we landed here
and then i had to stay up
until [ __ ] about 9 30 at night
to try and get on the clock and uh i
don't know
took a couple of days i kept bitching
about being jet lagged
to the point i think dawn irero was
gonna slap me in the face
i think i had like 14 conversations with
him about how i just
i couldn't go to sleep you know in the
lovely mia
you know she's more of a hippie free
spirit than i am right
she just took sleeping pills the first
night and was fine
and i'm all sitting here you know trying
to be [ __ ] johnny natural
bitching about what the [ __ ] they do to
your liver like i'm like i'm some sort
of a doctor
you know so finally the third day here i
actually took some sleeping pills
and i slept through the night and i felt
great you know
so there's one for the druggies hey man
just take his sleep and kill me and
it actually works um
so anyways i performed at this uh sydney
opera house
downstairs in the basement was a
400-seater and
did three nights every show was packed
and uh just great crowds
and it was a total this this trip was a
total success
and i'm definitely coming back here
because
not only did the people come out uh
it's just a great country i don't have
one
[ __ ] bad thing to say about australia
other than the fact that sydney is
expensive jesus christ
is his [ __ ] place expensive and i
lived in new york city and that place is
expensive
okay it's not like i'm some sort of
redheaded farm boy over here
okay you're not talking to [ __ ] huck
finn you know i'm not sitting here
barefoot with a goddamn fishing pole
over my shoulder
all right oh i got one bad thing one bad
[ __ ] thing
all right last night
we were coming back from watching these
bats fly out of the park
they call them flying foxes i guess
they're furry it was
night it was night time and they're all
you know hundreds of [ __ ] bats flying
out it was awesome
and um so we're hungry
and uh we're gonna go to the burger king
out here but they don't call it burger
king they call it hungry jacks
because evidently there was some other
guy out here already had a place called
burger king and he sued the burger king
corporation
somehow he won so for some reason burger
king
settled on the name hungry jacks
i don't know why i don't know why
but they have the exact same logo in the
menu
so we go into hungry jacks
and as we're standing there all of a
sudden this guy in a tank top comes in
with these two blonde girls and one of
them is just
loud is [ __ ] hell
like i'm standing there and then she
goes like hey
it's a crazy [ __ ] laugh like
really close to my ear like and i'm
thinking did she just do that to [ __ ]
with me or can she not
handle her alcohol and then
i guess you know on their cell phones
you can get they had some coupon for a
free burger or something
so she goes look i got a coupon for a
free burger she and then as she's
she [ __ ] reached past my face and
shook her cell phone
in front of my [ __ ] face
and i i can't believe i didn't slap her
[ __ ] phone down into the fryer later
it's been
bugging me and uh when she went to order
she
she she said to the guy behind the couch
she goes just making cheese just making
cheese just making cheese like three
times in a [ __ ] row
just being a total obnoxious [ __ ]
and i
tried to not let her get to me
but i just kept replaying that [ __ ]
shaking the phone in my face
she did it she shook it right in my
[ __ ] face and i didn't do anything
i was so like surprised and then there's
that that weird like
it's a woman so you got to do the math
like what do i do like i i'm telling you
the amount of times today
the the [ __ ] violent thoughts
i kept trying to think of anything i
could have said anything i could have
done the only solution i could have
thought of other than
what i did which was nothing was what
they were all violent solutions
i thought about what if i just took my
shake and dumped it over her head
and the fantasy immediately went to me
taking a burger
and like mushing in her in her face
slash
like punching her with what the palm of
my hand through the bread
which would be considered assault i
thought about
dragging her out by her [ __ ] hair
and then throwing her cell phone like
[ __ ] randy johnson
in his heyday and having it smash
right above her head and then just
sitting watching her cry as i went back
in and got my food
and some and somehow in all of these i
never never got arrested
but uh that was the only one bad thing
like this girl was like
so overdue for a [ __ ]
ass kicking um
i really wish i i just knew like
you know those chicks who fight in the
ufc i just wish
i knew one that was in the vicinity and
could have just had her come in
and dress like really like you know all
girly girly and just kind of act
sheepish and just let that girl come up
and do the obnoxious thing that's
[ __ ] that she was doing oh my god i
would i would
oh i would have paid 500 bucks
to to to have a woman not just if there
was a service
i would have paid 500 to [ __ ]
watch a woman go in and just knock this
[ __ ] out because she
just it wouldn't it would have made her
a better person
it really would have like today i'm
[ __ ] sitting here you know doing
touristy [ __ ]
i walked from uh with a bondi beach to
coochie beach
or whatever [ __ ] incredible
they got all these uh they were the sand
sculpted i don't know what the [ __ ] they
call them
sculptures and stuff i'll be honest with
you i could give a flying [ __ ] about
them
you know sculptures you know what they
do they take like a garden hose and some
pcp
pipe or whatever the [ __ ] it is you know
they take junk from the kitchen and they
make like a [ __ ]
i don't know what a rocket ship out of
it yeah i i just i've never been into it
it's clever
but you've seen one you've seen them all
nia on the other hand absolutely [ __ ]
loves them so she's stopping at every
goddamn one of them
it's windy as hell i got salt spray in
my face but i'm like
i'm liking it though i'm liking the uh
the elements but
um but half of the walk
i just kept thinking of grabbing that
girl last night
by her hair and throwing her off the
cliff
you know she lives
but she breaks her [ __ ] hip and she
deserves it
you know and when she looks at me like
why i just say cuz you're a [ __ ]
and that's the end of the fantasy is
that bad
other than that i had a great [ __ ]
time out here
and i'll tell you all about it right
after uh
i do a couple little ads here what do we
got here
uh lending tree um if you're if you have
a mortgage on your home
and you haven't looked at refinancing uh
you need to act now rates are at
three point one two five percent apr
which is
at an all-time low if you go to try
lendingtree.com
complete an easy form that takes less
than five minutes you will have up to
four lenders sending you
options to review and compare try
lendingtree.com now and if you enter the
code
bur burr you will receive a free
mortgage gr
mortgage guide all right www
or go to trylendingtree.com excuse me
um anyways so back to my trip here
back to my trip here um what did i do
i went to the zoo i went to the zoo
and earlier that morning one of the
zookeepers
unfortunately a lovely woman got crushed
against the wall by uh
a baby elephant or an adolescent one
you know and everybody was feeling bad
for her and we all hope that she gets
better but you know it's one of those
[ __ ] deals
you uh they don't want to be there
that was the overwhelming vibe that i
got well especially the [ __ ]
chimpanzees and the gorillas
okay you know what i would love what i
would absolutely love
is to go to church someday and listen to
some guy
speak in that [ __ ] creationism
mumbo [ __ ] jumbo and in the
background just have a bunch of apes
sitting in cages staring at people in
the [ __ ] crowd
of the church because i'm going to tell
you something right now i don't give a
[ __ ]
how much you're into jesus how much
you're into muhammad
whatever the [ __ ] you're into there's no
way to look a [ __ ] monkey in the eye
and not know exactly where the hell we
came from
[Laughter]
there's just no way somewhere along the
line
they broke left and we broke right but
i'm telling you if you go up the family
tree
[ __ ] long enough look at my dumb face
you're telling me i'm not half orangutan
there's no [ __ ] way there's no
goddamn way those [ __ ]
they they are they are just a [ __ ] hair
away
from being human and they're they're
aware that they're being watched
they don't want to be in there you know
it was really bad
they had this giant area where they were
playing and then they had this one area
where they could kind of walk into like
this little
cave you know and they walk into the
cave
trying to get a little [ __ ] peace and
quiet just don't want to be stared at
anymore
and there's a big window so we can see
him in there and i see this one goes in
there and i of course run up like the
taurus that i am
and this [ __ ] gets in there
starts going
[ __ ] slapping the walls and jumping
around
and i said to neil like that one does
not is is
that's the one right there that's gonna
rip your face off because
you know that dude's the man
and he's caged up all right you got a
[ __ ] alpha male there like
he's not a [ __ ] and he doesn't want to
be in there and
him just slapping the wall and whatever
the [ __ ] he just yelled in chimpanzee
if he translated it to english would
basically be like
you [ __ ] are so lucky that
glass is there because if you weren't
i rip all your faces off i'd rip a
couple feet off and a bunch of ball bags
so consider yourself lucky so anyway so
i leave
nia stays and all of a sudden the monkey
starts [ __ ] acting up and somebody's
standing there going he's
saying he's gonna charge the glass and
that's exactly what the thing did
and everybody jumped back and
uh and then another monkey ran in there
and all the
humans were like oh they're gonna fight
and when the other monkey ran in there
after the other
the alpha chimp flipped out when he ran
in there the two of them just hugged
each other
and then they sat down and started
grooming one another
it just made me feel bad you know
i don't mind rep you know you're gonna
stick something in a cage make it a
reptile
those [ __ ] idiots they don't know
what's going on you know
i gotta do is throw a dead mouse at them
every couple of hours and they're fine
the reptiles are the mouth-breathing
morons of the [ __ ] animal kingdom
they just they they're clueless you know
it's like
like those people that sit out in the
bleachers you know
those jackasses those are reptiles
um
speaking of which um
speaking of sports i've tried to keep up
on the sports i've been actually you
know something i've been over here so
long i'm starting to like cricket
which i got to tell you something right
now you know as much as they [ __ ] about
uh
help me moving this computer isn't
making a bunch of noises
um as much as people [ __ ] about how
difficult hockey is to watch on tv
you ain't seen [ __ ] until you try to
watch a game of cricket
when there's nobody there to explain
what the [ __ ] is going on
um for you yanks out there who never
seen the goddamn game
and it looks like baseball played with a
fraternity paddle
do you know that that field is 360
degrees there's no
foul balls you foul tip that
[ __ ] and it goes over the wall
behind you
that's six runs that's what you get for
a home run
six runs it gets to the wall that's four
runs there's
two guys with paddles when you hit the
ball they both try they run at each
other go to each other's bases
and if they can do it before those [ __ ]
get the ball in that's a run or two or
something like that
and they play they have like [ __ ] 50
outs
and they got a quicker game 20 something
or other that only takes a day but
a cricket match takes five [ __ ] days
good lord he thought baseball was born
but i gotta admit after a while i kind
of started to get into it
got into it a little bit but um
i don't know what else did i do out here
so we went to the zoo that was a great
time
um other than the fact you're just
looking into the eyes of animals that
don't want to [ __ ] be there
but uh oh by the way the two major
animals here
koalas and kangaroos not a fan of either
one
now that i've seen them up close koalas
like
they just got that look on their face
it's depressing you know i've been i was
joking on stage
my shows down here i was saying the
reason why i didn't like koalas because
when i looked at
into a koala bear's face it reminded me
of every time i quit in life
you know they just have that [ __ ] you
know what's the point man
you know they're just sitting there high
off that [ __ ] eucalyptus [ __ ] they
eat
they're like potheads for some reason
they remind me of tom bosley
you know mr c mr cunningham on happy
days like if mr cunningham
was a [ __ ] animal he he he would be a
koala bear
mr cunningham would be not tom bosley
okay
because obviously he didn't sit around
do nothing the guy made it as a [ __ ]
character actor
all right and kangaroos are our [ __ ]
rats they're rodents
they got this little [ __ ] head that's
really weird they just they're just
creepy
all right and and my version of a
kangaroo were those
funny ones that they drew in cartoons
they're not funny at all
they're [ __ ] like six feet six feet
one they're like as big as eli
manning and they can uh you know
basically rip your guts out with their
front feet
if they choose and uh and they can jump
twice as far as michael jordan so that's
that's pretty scary
see i learned [ __ ] when i was over here
you know you guys just think i'm going
around drinking [ __ ] beers which i
did
really bill can you recommend a good
aussie beer yes i can
uh little creatures pale ale it was
[ __ ] delicious
um all right i'm trying to space out do
a little better job here with the uh the
advertising this week i'll just read
them real quick
one at a time here and then get back to
the podcast uh amazon.com uh thanks
again for helping to support the show
by going to my amazon banner on
www.billbird.com
podcast page before you buy something
online
um this one extra sep helps support the
cost
of producing the podcast as well as
help the uh the wounded warrior project
where i give a percentage of my
advertising revenue to
so thanks again for going there there
you go
bing bang boom you like that quick
commercials this week
back to the podcast oh so this morning
my patriots the new england patriots
were playing the green
[ __ ] the new york jets
they were playing them i thought at four
in the morning
they were actually the four o'clock game
which was seven in the morning here so i
got up at four in the morning
and i actually watched on my computer
um i watched um
what did i watch i watched the giants
versus the redskins
thanks to my opening act my support as
they call it out here nick cody hooked
me up
with this nfl username and um and
password
and i was able to watch most of that
game before crapped out on me
and then i had to go to uh i had to go
to a casino which was five minutes down
the [ __ ] road but there's so much
traffic here in sydney and they only
have like two lanes on each side
it took forever to get over there um
and i watched the patriots versus the
jets jesus
jesus and you know what i saw during
that game i saw two teams that are not
going to win the super bowl this year
um i actually think rex ryan is doing a
hell of a [ __ ] job considering
all the injuries that they have and and
belichick is doing a hell of a job
considering we have
absolutely no secondary whatsoever they
definitely played better this week but
um
you know we won the game but i i can't i
can't even talk [ __ ]
it's like we we we blew the game and
then they
they and then the jets were like oh no
you don't
oh no you don't we're gonna blow the
game how dare you try to make us win
this game and then the patriots like
well wait a minute we don't want to win
this game
you win the game yeah we'll fumble the
ball during the kickoff
the jets go oh okay well we'll we'll
we'll see your fumble and we'll drop an
easy pass
and just kick a field goal um
i don't know if we just had somebody i
was i gotta be honest with you i was
really surprised that we won that game
because i really
you know defense wins games and i felt
that the jets had a better defense
or have a better defense that we do even
though grievous is out
um cro marty's still a great player
and uh we just don't we just don't have
that guy
in the [ __ ] secondary but uh but he
was hilarious i i can't even if i even
[ __ ] told this story yet because i
had to start this podcast three [ __ ]
times because it's so weird
to be doing this without hearing myself
headphones and all that type of [ __ ]
but anyways um i went over to the star
casino
you know what's hilarious is i'm i'm
like 50 50 whether i already told this
story i hope i didn't
um i went over there and there
there was nobody there i walked into
this sports book there was nobody there
there was this asian dude playing some
weird game in the corner
and i had the whole place to myself it
was actually kind of cool
and uh i don't know is it weird that it
like
i got over there by nine in the morning
i'd watched the first half on the
computer before crapped out on me
at nine in the morning i went over there
and i just started drinking
by myself i had three beers i told
myself
i was only gonna have two but then once
we [ __ ] up
and fumbled i was like ah [ __ ] it i'll
have it
i'm gonna [ __ ] drink my sorrows away
because we're gonna lose this game and
somehow we won
you know anybody go to the game out
there how many [ __ ]
fair weather fans left after we fumbled
the [ __ ] kickoff
trying to beat the traffic those douche
bags
so uh i don't know i'm psyched that we
won but in the long run
is is it really going to help the
patriots
you know what it is you know what's
really hurting the patriots how good tom
brady is
and bill belichick and our offenses
because we win so many [ __ ] games
that we shouldn't
and uh then we don't get a high draft
pick and we really need to
we need to get somebody is anybody
coming out of college that's just
going to be a lights out cornerback
because god knows we could [ __ ] use
one
oh and by the way i absolutely [ __ ]
hate
those old school new england patriot
uniforms
and i know there's a lot of people that
like him but all i i see those and i get
sick to my stomach
i see those uniforms and all i think of
is dan marino throwing for 500 yards
you know i think of the bears patriots
super bowl
i think a tony eason
um irving fryer before he got his [ __ ]
together
um i i roughing the passer
against the [ __ ] oakland raiders in
that's all i think of i just think of
losing or coming close to winning and
then [ __ ] losing that's all i think
of about whenever i see those
those uniforms although you know if i
see a t-shirt that has the old pat
patriot
helmet on it i'm a sucker and i'll buy
it but i i hate seeing us
i just hate seeing us wear those
uniforms it's it's just not a good time
i imagine people who uh tampa bay
buccaneers
fans probably feel the same way when you
have the creamsicle uniforms
doesn't that just remind you of owen 14.
i guess you had doug williams you had
that one year in like 79 where you got
all the way to the
uh the nfc championship
game where i believe the los angeles
rams beat you nine to nothing
norman cromwell kicked three field goals
isn't that what happened
and then they played the pittsburgh
steelers the roided up pittsburgh
steelers by the way
that's for that [ __ ] on twitter that
gave me [ __ ] about the patriots cheating
it's always funny to hear a steeler fan
talk about cheating you really should go
back and see
why you had the steel curtain it should
have said the steroid curtain
jesus christ even terry bradshaw
admitted that he was using roids
um but whatever whatever they got
cenegenics now they're giving them to
[ __ ] old people
um so anyways how far into this [ __ ]
horribly recorded podcast am i oh half
hour look at that
moving right along let's uh let's turn
on the [ __ ] light here
oh by the way i didn't make it up to the
great barrier reef
i didn't make it up there it was just
going to be too much of a thrash
and uh i actually found out how to do it
the right way
you know but granted i heard that
they're not going to allow the public to
go to the great barrier reef for much
longer and if they don't
what are you going to do you know what i
mean i think the barrier reef
is more important than uh this freckle
face [ __ ] actually seeing it um let's
let's get to uh a question for this week
it is an advice one uh brother-in-law
bill
so my brother-in-law is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he is the poster boy for napoleon
complex
he smacks his wife around jesus christ
doesn't keep groceries in the fridge for
his kids
talk [ __ ] about how he'll eat my lunch
to people
once he has a couple of whiskeys and
cokes in him
the guy is a real piece of [ __ ]
despite all of this i've never judged
the [ __ ]
never made a big thing out of his drunk
[ __ ] talking on me
always gave him the benefit of the doubt
well did you judge him for [ __ ]
slapping your sister around
right if he's your brother-in-law then
his wife has to be your sister
or is it on your could it be on your
wife's side
i don't know how that [ __ ] works i never
understood that this is my third cousin
that
doesn't mean [ __ ] to me i don't know
what that means do you have three
cousins
he's three times removed um anyways a
couple weeks ago it all came to a head
and then
i ended up having to kick his [ __ ]
ass after he showed up
to my two-year-old daughter's birthday
party drunk and caused a scene in front
of my family
i'll be the first to tell you that i
don't like confrontation
i don't walk around like i'm some badass
tough guy
this stuff has been brewing for a while
though and that night i had no choice
but to grant his wish and beat the [ __ ]
out of him well good for you
i gotta say it felt pretty [ __ ] good
too i imagine it did it feels good for
me to find out that you did it
um anyway so fast forward a little bit
my wife's sister is now sending text
messages
about him wanting a rematch blah blah
blah also it's your wife's sister that
he's slapping around
well this guy wants a rematch the guy
writes
l-o-l we live in close proximity so it
is not unusual to see these slugs
at the same grocery store liquor store
gas station etc
so when the time comes and i do see this
stupid little [ __ ]
how do i play it i have nothing to prove
i don't like to fight
i'm 31 years old and have a family but
i'm s
but i'm certain this [ __ ] will put me in
a position
when i do see him if you were me
how would you go about handling this
situation when it does arise
which i'm sure it will sooner or later
thanks bill
um
what would i do i call him up
i call the guy up the lovely mia
everybody
how are you um i would call the guy up
and uh
i try it that way call him up while he's
sober and you're sober you do it over
the phone so
it doesn't escalate to a physical thing
and i would just say listen
i heard that you're saying that you want
to rematch and all that type
of stuff all right i don't want to fight
you
that's not what i want to do but if you
put me in a position
i will defend myself and the outcome is
going to be the same
all right stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
learn how to hold your alcohol all right
but i'm going to tell you right now i am
not looking for a fight
but if you come at me i am going to
pound
your short little ass into the [ __ ]
ground
in front of your wife and kids all right
that's what i'm gonna do
and by the way stop slapping around your
wife
i know that's probably bad advice maybe
say something better than that
but um do it over the phone
is there a nice way to say that just say
listen man i don't want to fight you all
right i heard you want to rematch
it's unfortunate that things got
physical that that's the route you go
because you won the fight so there's no
re you don't have to gloat he knows what
happened
all right you know you got out of hand
you know maybe you ought to uh go to a.a
or something
you know you seem to be uh really chippy
when you have a couple of drinks
um and then when he starts yelling all
this stuff just say listen
i didn't call up to argue with you i'm
just telling you i don't want to fight
you again
all right please don't put me in a
position to have to fight you again
all right just leave it there ah you
know what
you guys you know what it's inevitable
you guys are gonna fight
all right so just drop that guy give him
a [ __ ] straight right just [ __ ]
brighten his [ __ ] chops
why don't you go over there just go over
there and fight him again
kick his ass and then throw him in the
bushes and just laugh as you watch that
little [ __ ] have to crawl out of them
you know you know what i'm worried about
sir is that you're going to end up
getting sued
you know that's something that the
little bastard will do
this guy near he's actually he [ __ ] i
don't know he slaps his wife around
doesn't keep gross she's in the fridge
you can't hold his alcohol the guy that
wrote you
no no no no the guy that wrote me this
is his brother-in-law
his brother-in-law honestly wraps around
his sister
no i don't know i think it's his wife's
sister
i mean i don't get it i don't get what's
going on here i don't know what we're
talking about i mean
because if he's slapping around your
sister you should do what james khan did
in the in the godfather
and beat the [ __ ] out of him with every
you know trash can on the block
i i don't know i i i don't it seems real
i don't know for some reason his
question wasn't about how do i get him
to stop
hitting his wife yeah that's kind of the
main issue
isn't it i don't know i don't think that
that's
i don't think in his world it is these
might be uh
that oh god do you see that show gypsy
blood when we were over here
yeah yeah like those guys like [ __ ]
they did their they have [ __ ] fights
they kick the family dog around
and they have their kids sit there be
have half hour fights with each other
taking punches to the head and this and
they're going no you got it you got to
convince this woman to leave this
[ __ ] that's the thing
uh you know what it's that's that's a
real
why wouldn't you do that he's slapping
her around why wouldn't he try to tell
her
to leave him well why wouldn't she leave
you know what i mean what do you mean
there's a there's a million reasons why
people stay in abusive relationships
it's not so black and white like oh
you're getting beat up leave it's
sometimes more complicated than that
well yeah but you can't just go over and
be like hey you know what you should
leave like like she doesn't know
the guy's slapping her around it's like
you gotta have something like hey you
should leave and i have an apartment for
you
well yeah sure of course like that's the
like because other than that you're like
that's like walking up somebody broke
going you should win the lottery
no it's it isn't all right well i'm
stupid
listen don't get mad at me okay i have
to make it i have to keep it funny i
have to keep it funny
i i understand i understand the guy
shouldn't be hitting the girl and he
should try and help him out i mean
i mean that goes without saying
what what what are they supposed to do
i don't know i mean yeah that's a tough
one
but i mean if the wife wasn't around the
husband it might
it might help a little might help a lot
sounds like
i don't know they should stuff that
little [ __ ] in a trash can put duct
tape over the lid
poke some holes in there so the [ __ ] can
still breathe and then just move his
wife out to a safe place
there you go and then roll the guy down
the hill
all right there's a dilemma for you nia
if if you could be invisible for a day
what would you do invisible for a day
what would you do um
[Music]
i don't know i would probably sit in on
people's therapy sessions
really yeah i would because i'm really
interested in that kind of stuff anyway
psychology and you know you can just be
a therapist
i know i i wanted to be a therapist for
a long time
yeah i always said like if i wasn't
doing what i'm doing now i'd maybe like
go back to school for it
but yeah you could be invisible for a
day that's what you would do
i think i would is that weird it's weird
to me
because i'm a p i'm obviously what
you're way
nicer a person than i am oh why what
would you do
oh my god there's a zillion things
everything from look up women's dresses
what are you [ __ ] ten years old yeah
to
uh you can just go online and just see
women
not the same vaginal canal okay so you
don't need to like
i just lay down weird sidewalk yeah like
a little boy
i'd either do that that's the dumbest
what a waste of time
wait that's a
or i would i go to the cia building and
i just start reading files
that sounds more like you while i looked
up dresses of ages
yeah you got to do something perverted
look i'm just being honest there's no
way i could handle the power of being
invisible you don't have to be invisible
in order to see
women's like private parts that doesn't
require
yeah you don't ability you can just do
it on the internet yeah but that's not
the same
that's like i can also watch that
[ __ ] oliver stone jfk movie
that's not like walking into the cia
building and reading all the stuff
before they black it out
you know okay but that makes more sense
to do invisible
rather than look up somebody's skirt
whatever it's your [ __ ] invisibility
yeah stop taking my invisibility away
ugh lame
what's the next one me you know
something near my cia thing was better
than you said in your therapy session
that's like that's like a job you could
just go do that that's like what would
you do if you were invisible
um i'd go to a construction house a
construction
site and watch him build a house just be
a construction worker
no and do it that it's more about like
being nosy about people's business
that's why i want to be invisible
well what you're doing is the female
version of me looking up a dress
i'm looking into their mind well look if
if
i'm automatically deeper than you if
guys deeper
than you if guys genitalia looked a
little better you'd be laying down on
the sidewalk too looking at ball bags
gross i know so no one wants to look at
a ball back exactly so that's why you're
not a better person but yeah but
everyone wants to see a hoo-ha
um all right dilemma
all right you were just given a yacht
what would you name it
it's not really a dilemma but uh yeah
why is that a dilemma
[ __ ] i was just giving a million dollar
boat what would you name it
hmm i don't know i would i would name it
tenderheaded
oh god nia it's my name of my company
it's my whole branding identity
it's tenderheaded why wouldn't i know
it's supposed to be something kind of
like
funny what are you gonna name it go [ __ ]
yourself
i know off the grid uh kilo aboard
no i told you if i ever had a boat i
would definitely there's no way i would
not be
moving drugs i wouldn't be able to
handle that power
just taking a [ __ ] water taxi just
being out there it's like i'm out on the
water there's nobody out here
you know i could just i would i would
[ __ ]
i would have every once in a while not
all the time every once in a while i
would have a brick of weed
or a kilo of coke and i would just be
out there
by myself just out there naked just
[ __ ]
jerking off on the seas and just having
a good time i wouldn't handle i could i
you know there's a reason why i'm where
i'm at in society god knows better
every once in a while he [ __ ] up and
then he lets a crazy person through
um all right how far are we into this
thing i'm really hoping this isn't gonna
sound [ __ ]
why don't you horrific it and listen to
it for a second i i did
that sounds it sounds like i'm in a
[ __ ] tin can it's the best i can do
this there's no like levels here that i
can [ __ ] with
and i don't know um can you
can you put that thing all the way to
the right does that do anything
i don't know what that does that that
maybe turns it up
yeah i have no idea how have you enjoyed
being in uh australia
oh i've loved it it's been amazing and
shout out to all the cool people that
came to your show
absolutely and were nice enough to say
hi to me
oh yeah a lot of people were like they
were like the lovely nia yeah that was
really nice so
shout out to all you guys that said
hello to me that was nice it made me
feel really uh
special and welcome and now this city is
amazing
having a great time definitely want to
come back that was probably the nicest
11 seconds ever on it was very sincere
it's true i've felt very welcomed by
that okay
all right jesus christ it's true
i really liked it people in australia
are
so nice you know what i think it's time
to talk about
sweet sweetest day all right mr burr
love the podcast uh on oh you know what
i go wait i
gotta i gotta read i gotta read uh a
commercial here real quick
uh what the hell is this one stamps.com
everybody
you know the drill huh you want to go to
the post office for the rest of your
life good
that's your choice you know what the
rest of us are doing we're going to
stamps.com
we're bringing the post office into our
dwellings our tent city our homes our
houses our
teepees um wouldn't it be great if you
could have a uh if you could print
legal postage at home any time of the
day
while invisible looking up somebody's
skirt um
look you know what you get you get the
scale
you get uh you get a no risk trial you
use my last name burp b-u-r-r for the
special offer
plus 110 bonus offer includes the
digital scale and up to
dollars free postage you're getting 55
dollars for free
they give you a little scale you know so
if you got something you want to put in
a box you want to figure out the postage
they can do that it's just
like the post office except it's in your
house it's awesome
i use it whenever i send out my dvds
and i highly recommend it go to
stance.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur
burr and you'll get your 55 free bonus
postage
at stamp stop comment or burr all right
on to the sweetest day
mr burr i love the podcast okay on to my
question
my wife keeps busting my balls
to participate in what i call a [ __ ]
holiday
yeah it's called sweet sweetest day i've
never even heard of this
says certain areas of the midwest
celebrate something called
sweetest day on the third saturday in
october
it's just another excuse for cards
flowers candy etc
i am originally from new orleans new
orleans and didn't move to the midwest
until 2009
until then i was unaware of this i was
unaware this holiday even existed
this is the first time hearing of it too
sir i've never heard of this
no at all exactly it says i am also in
the military so we live
outside of ohio the first six years of
our marriage
um this holiday was never even mentioned
once during that time
so every year since moving to cincinnati
i have refused to partake
like clockwork every year i catch flack
because my wife's friends slash family
brag about the gifts they received
am i being a dick for not participating
in this should i stand my ground or give
in to celebrating something with
only regional importance any help would
be appreciated go [ __ ] yourself
and happy swedish day
so do they not celebrate valentine's day
there this is basically what it is this
is an
extra valentine's day this is like when
the nfl wanted to add more games
and the players union was like [ __ ] that
we're already getting enough concussions
this is the valentine's day version of
that
so there's one in february and then
there's one in october
oh get her something nice so she doesn't
have to feel shitty in front of all
those people
what's the big deal get some flowers
this is what the deal get her some
perfume take her out to dinner
now wait a minute wait a minute what the
[ __ ] is she gonna get him
isn't it it's not a mutual thing
don't try to back your way out of this
you weren't even trying you weren't even
[ __ ] even remotely thinking about the
guy in this
well it wasn't until you just mentioned
it but yeah you weren't get her this
get her that what about him yeah you
already have valentine's day we already
have to buy you
[ __ ] you guys don't buy us a [ __ ]
thing on that side not true what have
you ever gotten me for valentine's day
that's a chat that's a joke
i love that too like how you guys
consider sex like that's a chore for you
like it doesn't feel good
i wish it was a holiday where i just
like let you blow me
after you took me out isn't it there's
something like that isn't that something
that men are trying to get going
that's something i was trying to get
going it's called steak and a [ __ ]
day
that's right you know what and i'm
telling you
if if your lady is a champion she'll
actually enjoy doing that making you a
steak
and [ __ ] blowing you yeah well maybe
that's the compromise let's do something
for each other on the sweetest day how
about that we'll both
you know yeah you know what i want you
to do you want i want you to do for me
on
on sweetest day me yeah what i want you
to forget that it exists
[Laughter]
and my gift to you is that i'll do the
exact same thing give me a [ __ ] break
you want to go out
if you want to go out one night just say
you want to go out don't do it with this
[ __ ]
i have to go out and go buy a bunch of
candies and all that crap
who came up with this sweetest day thing
the [ __ ] people who make the candy
yeah but how come jesus christ do you
have to be invisible looking for
files to figure that out but gee
who came up with the suzuki samurai tips
over easily the people who make the jeep
but how come we haven't heard of it
though
how come yeah it's a regional thing like
why is it
because people in cincinnati are dumb
and they don't realize
that they're getting [ __ ] over i don't
know why i don't know why i have no idea
i i don't know i don't know why it goes
on there
yeah i mean it's definitely kind of
ridiculous to have to participate it
just because everybody else it's not
kind of ridiculous it's completely
[ __ ] ridiculous
well they can compromise by both doing
let's do like a special day together and
it's it's a together thing as opposed to
let me go out and buy you stuff so just
you can show off you know something
about all of this [ __ ]
that's just [ __ ] that should be going on
in your relationship anyways
you shouldn't have to [ __ ] go you
know that you know hallmark said stand
up and salute and then you stand up like
a [ __ ] zombie
you know [ __ ] you hallmark go [ __ ]
yourself [ __ ] all your days
[ __ ] all of that what do we do every
year for valentine's day
we go out the day before valentine's day
day after day after
so you don't even know you know not on
valentine's day to avoid the crowds
because snaps go out there in the
inflated crisis and we have a great time
oh it's phenomenal yeah february 15th is
one of the greatest nights
yeah you'll ever go out to dinner
nobody's out
you just do you do it that way so what
so what should he say to his wife about
this should he just be like i'm not
just being this [ __ ] i don't want
her to have to go through what i go
through this is what you should have to
do he should go hey sweetie
and just when she looks
no just grab his dick i got your holiday
right here
i'll pour some sugar right on my dick
all right there you go there's your
[ __ ] blow pop
[Laughter]
no it's stupid um she probably knows
it's stupid too
but you know everybody else is like oh
he didn't get who's this brad
brad no we don't name names oh we don't
name names it's chad
chad yeah there you go he wrote it on
the thing
well yeah oh it's my fault for showing
it to you
oh god look um yeah the third saturday
in october
yeah that's weird well
i i i it's it's yet another one-way
holiday this is what i would say
that would be like
i would just screw that up look i
there's already a valentine's day
christmas is right around the corner you
know what i mean
and it's like when was the last time you
made me a steak and blew me because it's
[ __ ]
steak and a blow job that we got we
really have to come up with a day
maybe it should be the third saturday of
october
october is halloween swedish let's
figure this out let's
let's let's let's figure this out all
right okay january's new year's
yeah february valentine's day and abe
lincoln's birthday or george washington
or something like that it's black
history month
black history month okay so that's out
um march march is saint patrick's day
we got we there's got to be a month left
that feels like something that would
fall in line with saint patrick's day
it's taking a blow dry day it sounds
like sometimes
a drunken irish fool would come up yeah
then it gets too frat boy and then you
get that then it becomes date rape day
yeah that's true then it becomes rapey
april
is easter and april fool's day
and hitler's birthday so that's out 420
man
may mother's day memorial day
god damn it
june is father's day father's day june
that's weird huh
like for father's day like if your
husband's a father give a mistake and
blow jobs yeah
snake in a [ __ ] two bits right
do you wanna stay i don't know no all
right july that's it's fourth
independence day yeah that works
no it's not you know american no it
feels like more of a fall holiday
honestly
steak and a blow job what about august
there's nothing in august
yeah that's yeah august is good there
you go it's the end of the summer august
or september
corn is in season it's very phallic
looking
there you go august august we'll come up
with a date
the 17th okay all right august 17th
that's right stake in a [ __ ]
lucky seven and one [ __ ]
you heard it here at first folks august
17.
staking a [ __ ] day yeah you know what
there's a lot of women out there that
are actually going to enjoy doing that
put it in the calendar so when it comes
up next year you make a big announcement
about it i'm gonna get this thing going
i have to
get it trending on twitter well like to
get it going i gotta get [ __ ] out of
there
it's gotta be uh steak and bj
well what you do is the steak thing
you'd be supporting uh
beef farmers right so you added john
cougar mellencamp sort of farm aid thing
to it
and that's amazing and then the blowj
yeah we get willie nelson and all those
guys to do it
and then the uh the job that's a tough
one hey there you go there's there's you
have podcast listeners there's your
homework for the week
how can i sell this thing um without
people saying that it's completely
[ __ ] sexist
all right that's it all right we're
winding down here on the podcast let me
make sure
i've gotten everything that i need to
get to what are we up to here 54 minutes
of tin can listening
um all right amazon lending tree already
did that
game fly game fly there we go
gamefly.com everybody hey would you like
8 000 video games at your fingertips
with a 15
free 15 day free trial go to gamefly.com
or through the gamefly banner on my
website podcast page
the free trial is a 23 value and you
will get two disks of whatever game
for whatever video game system you want
uh there's no strings attached if you
don't like the service just return the
games and cancel your subscription you
can't lose
gamefly is the best service out there to
play the new games again for a free
trial
15 day trial exclusive to listeners of
the monday morning podcast go to
gamefly.com
burr and uh
i'm required to do this one twice once
again lending tree everybody
interest rates are the lowest they've
ever been all-time low 3.125 you're
looking to refinance your mortgage
go to trylandingtree.com and now if
you're under the code bur
b-u-r-r you will receive a free mortgage
guide
all right back to the uh to the podcast
here fellatio fillet
all right that has alliteration but how
are you going to get the red states are
you going to get the bible beaters
you know what it needs to be one of
those underground holidays
you know yeah that's cool up the
mainstream like
i like it just like the podcast podcast
is we're we're kind of underground you
already blasted the hallmark they're
obviously not going to have anything to
do with it yeah
[ __ ] hallmark hallmark's right there
with nike
just do it keep sewing you piece of [ __ ]
give us the money
yeah it's so ridiculous um
and they all i talk about is the shame
of lance armstrong what about the shame
of having people have to sleep raw
sewage out of their [ __ ] houses
during the rainy season because you're
not paying them enough money that
they're gonna have a door
on their [ __ ] concrete dwelling
i don't think what are you gonna do
anyways anyways
um we got anything left oh here's the
last thing for this week uh learning
spanish
uh what's up bill i heard you bitching
about rosetta stone on your latest
podcast
i wasn't bitching about it i was
frustrated that uh
i don't have the time to commit to it we
were bitching
i was a bitching you always [ __ ] yeah
but i wasn't bitching about rosetta
stone
bitching that i couldn't get the [ __ ]
i'd lost the disc
i like rosetta stone okay all right then
he said dude that's old technology
it's like you're still trying to make
phone calls with one of those
backpack wind-up army phones we used in
vietnam jesus christ is it that old
yeah it's like he goes just give this a
try
it's a free website i'll [ __ ] you when
you're advertising you're trying to get
in here okay he says this
this other place the format
okay the format they have for learning a
language in my opinion
is far superior to rosetta stone
i'm i'm i'm guessing this person
actually makes some money
off this he goes plus there's no [ __ ]
software and it's free
tracks your progress and it allows you
to communicate with other users
if you're having trouble very helpful
just trying to help out a fellow ginger
all right ginger's got to stick together
i i'm a redhead
i'm from the states we're called
redheads all these people in the states
using that expression
ginger is [ __ ] hilarious to me
with your [ __ ] what who's austin
powers wait a minute out of nowhere
what's that ginger how is i know ginger
is
is red but what is it about ginger that
is red like where did they came up spice
isn't it the spice
yeah but if you look at a ginger you've
seen a ginger root before it's not
red no i haven't you have i've put it in
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah what are you
talking about yeah it's not red at all
oh i don't know how it came about but
maybe the dry maybe dry ginger
is right i don't think so i have no idea
anyway
um so you know what's funny too is how
people keep sending me
things saying that redheads are going to
be extinct
by the year 2080. it's like so will i be
i mean what
how's it gonna affect my i won't be
extinct
i'll be dead from [ __ ] old age
hopefully
i don't understand how redheads are
supposed to be extinct like a whole
like there will be no more people in the
world
who have red hair ever like what where
based on what
based on somebody said something on the
internet and all these [ __ ]
morons who aren't qualified
to pass it on yeah i'm going to go ahead
and say that that's probably an urban
myth
you know what's funny as i was
describing what they were doing i
realized that i described what i do on
stage every night
yeah by the way but that's the funny
upgrade with my shows
i was when i was out here your shows
were amazing i [ __ ] had a great god
damn time
i did i i can't wait to come back here
next time i come back here
it's over man i'm doing a whole [ __ ]
tour next time i'm gonna do
perth melbourne [ __ ]
was it bizbane and [ __ ] brisbane
brisbane adelaide
and uh and [ __ ] where are we
symphony what the [ __ ] it called
sydney i'm gonna do that whatever i'm
tired
all right that's the podcast this week
guys i'm sorry i shorted out my mixer
um i hope you enjoyed it um
next week i'll be back back to uh
i'll have to buy a new [ __ ] mixer and
i'll oh i don't know what i'm gonna do
oh you're gonna get rid of your ham
radio
wait it died i mean i don't know what to
tell you it [ __ ] died
all right well that's the podcast and
once again seriously no [ __ ] thank
you to everybody
who came uh to my shows here in sydney
i know a lot of people traveled a long
long ways yeah
to come to my shows i had an awesome
time um
and i am definitely without a [ __ ]
doubt coming back because uh australia
is the [ __ ] all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves have a good week
i'll talk to you later and thanks for
coming on with me neil all right you're
welcome
okay bye-bye
you